la vie chère c'est l'euro
les délocalisations c'est l'heure où
[Musique]
le chômage
c'est l'euro
la misère et la pauvreté c'est l'euro
s'il ya plus de choix budgétaires autant
donner la clé du parlement du président
de la république à la commission des
commissaires des commissaires c'est à
dire une dictature est-ce que l'euro
fonctionne et marchent bien tout le
monde sait que non on veut faire passer
aujourd'hui exactement le même texte
sans consulter les français moi
j'appelle ça un coup d'état c'est la
première fois depuis la libération que
le parlement français va voter un traité
qui a été refusée solennellement par le
peuple français deux ans avant
donc c'est plus qu'un vol c'est un viol
moi j'appelle les 16 millions de
français des lecteurs français qui ont
voté non en 2005 à ne pas se laisser
fouiller alors est ce qu'on voit la
souffrance des européens de réduire tous
ont amené une mauvaise politique
européenne seuls pas dire que votre
compte l'europe il avait de construire
l'europe sur des bases beaucoup plus
cela leur faut rendre à la france sa
liberté il faut qu'elles puissent se
protéger il faut qu'elle ait sa monnaie
il faut qu'elle soit libre de ses moyens
sinon on continuera dans la ruine avec
ce poison nous allons
on a eu l'embarras du choix pour
composer sans eux ce florilège
mais nicolas dupont aignan ça n'a pas
vraiment pris dans l'opinion est ce que
vous reconnaissez que l'euro est une
certaine idée européenne ont fini par
s'imposer l' esclavage de la france là
je persiste et je peux je ne retire pas
un mot de ce que j'ai dit même sur la
monnaie européenne à mais bien sûr
d'ailleurs vous verrez que ça ne tiendra
pas si longtemps qu'on croit c'est
impossible donc c'est ça et et c'est
pour ça que philippe séguin avait raison
et qu'on avait je persiste à penser que
nous avions raison
c'est l' esclavage de la france sa
misère sa pauvreté tout a été écrit dans
le discours pour la france de philippe
seguin ce pour moi qui ai inventé tout
ça est et ça s'applique et c'est
terrible parce que les français
finalement ont été enfermés là dedans on
voit le déficit commercial cette année
83 milliards donc plus de la moitié avec
nos partenaires voilà c'est une machine
à broyer le pays
un jour on s'en apercevra quand mais je
ne regrette rien parce que je le pense
je le pense toujours d'ailleurs toute ma
campagne de 2002 22 2017 2022 et puis
2022 2000 sera 2022 va être faite
là-dessus
pas obligatoire alors sur l'euro il y
aura une adaptation parce que c'est
tellement rentrée dans les moeurs qui va
falloir organiser une flexibilité mais
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le nouveau président de la banque
centrale a fait ce que j'avais
recommandé est ce que trichet voulait
pas faire quand il y avait ces paroles
c'est à dire qu'il à monétiser à mort
pour assouplir le système donc pour moi
acceptable aujourd'hui le système non il
accepta il n'est pas durable il est
transitoirement acceptable parce que je
pense et c'est ce que je dirai pour
cette élection je pense que d'abord il
faut retrouver nos frontières faut
retrouver la supériorité nos lois faut
déjà aller il faut déjà colmater les
brèches et puis sur l'euro on aura le
bras de fer avec l'allemagne et soit
l'allemagne accepte qu'on monétise et
c'est nous qui piègeront l'allemagne
soit l'allemagne refuse et
eh bien les pays du sud sont obligés
d'inventer autre chose donc de toutes
façons il n'y a pas d'exemple d'union
monétaire qui dure sur des bases qui ne
sont pas solides donc les faits me
donneront raison malheureusement c'est
beaucoup de chômage de souffrance de
perte de richesse pour la france
[Musique]